[Music]
so I was hired to be generating stubble
on this thing called the matrix the
sci-fi actually would come through and
pretty surreal visuals I called said hey
run go TT on reason the sci-fi movie I'm
like man no my boss said once you
audition
you'll be done here soon okay so I get
hit by a car and cut my head open look a
couple band-aids on it for sure if I'm
still bleeding from my head and he threw
a chalice keys in the background I see
Keanu Reeves in this big warehouse
before the first matrix he had neck
surgery so he's in a neck brace got a
big beard dripping in sweat doing kung
fu for everything and it's surreal
I need Keanu and he's like hey what's up
I'm like your neck okay oh yeah no
problem just that neck surgery jumps
right back into comes ooh
I get done with this auditions dripping
in sweat I just remember I can't look it
up just gives me a little nod like
pretty good that was like that's the
high point of my career I can't oh he's
give me a nod it's probably that you
know I see piano every day now because
we did John wick so I came on right
after they started principal photography
it was literally walking in off the
plane and going right into the
government Lobby choreography but the
time there are no digital squibs so
everything was practical first time when
Karen runs down the hallway and the guns
are going off and everybody's shooting
at him that was a week of prep just for
the special effects guys delaying all
the squib
so every time you do it take to get one
go at it and if you miss they send
another day every setting to blow it up
again the Chomsky said there's about
4,000 scripts in the wall so only yell
action you're probably not gonna be able
to see anything so she and I both had a
pretty much try to do the choreographies
with your eyes closed and I remember
looking at them one okay this could be a
little tricky like yeah okay and you
know
you nailed it first take the matrix is
kind of a game changer for all some work
and cinema and to this day I think it's
one of the best directed films I've ever
seen what they were doing was a ramping
effects the slow motion and how they
would go with bullet time and how they
would intercut between normal speed and
then slow motion and back it had a vibe
it had a slickness to it that we hadn't
really seen in any kind of action song a
lot of guys can try and copy the matrix
but it's not the same just put all those
little pieces together and then with
Chelsey's wanted to immerse it into a
world that was both real and extreme and
when you sit and watch that matrix
you are wrapped up in that movie we're
talking about the matrix today I'm going
to wash it again I mean how cool is it
that you know I get to watch The Matrix
with Daenerys and we still laugh when we
still cheer and defeat the actual neo
sitting in a chair both having a scotch
watching the majors and to see canneries
jump up and go yeah that's awesome
no your lighting is pretty cool